I returned to state of decay year one
Edition for exactly one reason lifeline
the third DLC lifelines one of those
good DLCs that takes the main game and
flips it on its head whereas in the
original players looked after a group of
cunning civilian survivors who stumbled
out of the wilderness and into the
zombie apocalypse think walking dead
lifeline takes place from the military
perspective trying to stop the fall in
the first place it could easily be one
of the short stories from the book World
War Z in which there is no cure no easy
answers and the human race is just gonna
have to fire up that gray matter and
claw their way back onto the food chain
one bullet and one sword swing at a time
what makes lifeline feel new is that
your tactics from the main game stop
working immediately in the original each
civilian survivor needed a particular
loadout to thrive a boomstick 30 rounds
three meds a piece of crowd control such
as a Molotov cocktail and a distraction
device to get away but most importantly
a sturdy car because the original
setting Trumble valley was rural and
diffused with that loadout you could
handle anything and gather enough
resources to turn a base into a
five-star resort zombie adjacent as a
soldier and lifeline your first reaction
when entering the city of danforth
is very different from the original game
it's one of strength
hell yeah a console' jur I've got so
much firepower let's stop the sambar
clips your second reaction will be in
the pit of your stomach holy crap that's
a lot more zombies than I have bullets
what you can lay down in fire and
lifeline zombies can lay down in bodies
and special infected you will be
expending walls of fire at such a
colossal rate that that false sense of
security quickly evaporates then you're
gonna start feeling like it's only a
matter of time before you get it and
you'll realize that lifeline is a war
story not a survivor story I'm still
figuring out exactly what I need to get
ahead and lifeline on a second
playthrough I may have some regrets and
getting a lot of good people killed
developing my new tactics but as a
soldier I no longer leave the wire
without as many mags medicine and
grenades as I can stuff in my pockets
and the trunk of my car
now I don't want to be a total state of
decay cheerleader this DLC still has
plenty of technical issues such as
zombies occasionally running through
walls it also felt odd to be playing a
military themed DLC
you still go out solo as opposed to in
squads and even though undead Labs has
commented on future titles having
multiplayer co-op potential lifeline
absolutely screams for it and it doesn't
have it but in the end I still love the
gameplay mechanics of state of decay
it's a game that makes me feel like the
zombie apocalypse is still going strong
what do you think they'll get out of
this sample the very last piece of a
secret weapon that'll kill all the zits
and return the world to normal nah I'm
just [ __ ] with you
no [ __ ] huh for us